hi there steve kaufman here
back from uh the long fest festival de
long in montreal tell you i want to talk
about
how language learning has become so much
easier today and how it's going to
continue to become easier first of all
long fest was a great
four or five days for me in montreal
it's such a wonderful bilingual city
multilingual city
uh the people at the conference of
course there's this tremendous sort of
feeling of everybody wanting to help
everybody everybody wanting to learn
from everybody everybody's learning
languages is just positive very
wonderful feeling so language learning
is becoming easier
um for example um on sunday it'll be
exactly three months since i started
learning turkish
if my tutor
agrees i will do a video showing you
sort of my progress and i feel now that
i'm progressing in all of these
languages which are different from
french spanish german whatever
and therefore more difficult and i'm
progressing faster because language
learning has become easier
a variety of reasons
one of which by the way is our mini
stories there's no question that these
60 mini stories with so much repetition
spoken at a natural tone you don't begin
with hello how are you the colors you
begin right in the language and you stay
more or less at that level
for 60 lessons and and it becomes a
little more difficult in that more
tenses are introduced
but in a sense you're gradually just
getting used to the language
and
i find that i'm speaking faster
so there are so many tools available
just the availability of mp3 the
availability for example now that we can
access
netflix or for that matter uh youtube
videos where there are
you know subtitles closed captions we
can bring those in as lessons and study
them at link for example they're just so
much more available um which reminds me
you know
i guess a year or two ago it was
announced by the canadian government
that they were going to spend 16 million
dollars to produce a language learning
website so that canadians would become
more bilingual they would learn the
other official language
and this was part of a 2.7 billion
dollar five-year program
whereby the canadian government felt
that they could increase bilingualism
outside quebec from six percent to seven
percent
2.7 billion dollars part of it is this
uh 16 million language learning website
another 16 million has gone to a thing
called the canadian language portal and
there was a presentation on this at the
long fest
and it just amounts to a
a less efficient version of google
translate really except that i guess to
some extent the the translations are
vetted
but you can look up a dictionary
uh
their justification is that you know
some usage might not be canadian and we
need to have canadian usage why that
matters is absolutely beyond me but
that's 16 million dollars
now their website the for language
learning
they they say is going to be um
available in 2020.
so it's been two years 16 million
dollars and it turns out that they've
given this work to the canadian
broadcasting corporation or hadoo canada
in french
well you know really
canadian broadcasting corporation had
your canada already has fabulous
language learning material it's all of
their programs that are on youtube and
they you can turn on the closed captions
and then with our link browser extension
you can bring all of that into link as a
lesson
and most canadians have had enough
either french
or english at school that they have
learned that they can probably access
these
tv programs if they are interested and
motivated and if they are not interested
and motivated
no language learning website is going to
help them
i suspect what will happen is that the
cbc will take all this money hire a
bunch of people
teachers develop a whole bunch of
exercises and drills and questions and
explanations and stuff
which is really a not necessary and b in
so far as explanations
because the world of language learning
has become so much easier it's all over
the web uh i can put a conjugating
dictionary for example that link as one
of the dictionaries and i do that
uh
for turkish verbs i go to a conjugating
dictionary and i see all the
conjugations kind of review them quickly
get back to my text so all of those
things are already available in this
wonderful world of easy language
learning
um
and of course i don't do drills and i'm
not convinced that they're useful uh i
mean you have only so much time to spend
on your language learning so are you
going to spend your time engaging with
content or are you going to spend your
time doing
answering questions and doing drills i
prefer to spend my time with
content now
admittedly the mini stores are not
tremendously engaging content but they
are designed with a lot of repetition we
have 60 of them
if there are any people out there who
would like to try their hand at writing
more in any language we're willing to
pay for that i'm not going to get into
how much or whatever but i would like to
expand that because
they are a constant repetition of the
key verbs the key phrases because after
all in learning any language you just
need to know how the verbs work which
you can google for how the nouns and
adjectives work which you can google for
the prepositions the pronouns how they
work there's only a few things that
matter word order you get a sense of
very quickly once you get into the
language you don't need to have that
explained in great detail
and so once you access easily access
explanations on how these key parts of
speech work after that you just need to
acquire words and expose yourself to the
language now to jump right into these tv
programs might be a little difficult uh
the 60 mini stories we have gets me you
know a fair distance to that
but there's still a bit of a gap there
so if we had another 60 mini stories
that would be great and if they were
written in uh you know chinese romanian
ukrainian it wouldn't matter that would
give us a little more cultural diversity
so to speak because the stories we now
have are written in english and
translated if we get stories written in
some other language we'll translate them
back to english get them translated into
other languages so yeah they might be a
little bit stilted but they'll again
have key
verbs key
uh kind of phrasing key conjunctions
that you need in order to learn the
language and they'll introduce a bit
more vocabulary
uh speaking of which
some uh you know publishers of language
learning material still don't get it so
i bought asimil for turkish
and when i was in montreal
and with it came a thumb drive and the
cds
i put the thumb drive in my computer
and um
they had every single sentence almost
like 30 seconds as a separate sound file
so that makes it very difficult to deal
with i can't for example
um
so anyway so that was no good so then i
threw the cds in and saw that there at
least they had one sound file per lesson
now with one sound file per lesson i was
able to put that sound file on
happyscribe and get a transcript because
i have a monthly
contract with happyscribe so i am
entitled to so many minutes of
transcription
now if i transcribe a podcast
i don't have any text to compare it to
but if i transcribe a lesson from asimil
then i can see in the book if there's
any minor you know mistakes in the
automatic transcription actually it's
pretty good
so now i had the transcripts
so then i had to painstakingly
painstakingly go through
and put each one of these transcripts so
i get it from happyscribe
download it copy paste and import it
into link 71 lessons that takes a long
time i still haven't imported the sound
files i still have to go in and tie the
sound files to the lesson so that i can
do all of those on link which is my
preferred way to study because i can
look up words i can be in sentence mode
all these things
wouldn't it be wonderful if and and when
we're in fukuoka the people from asimil
are going to be there and we will ask
them again
if we can integrate with their system
and i think we are continuing to develop
ways in which we can access
you know
material
television programs youtube videos
netflix
audiobook ebook and bring it in as
learning material at link
one thing of interest
and as i say this you know the acl mill
material which actually unlike the mini
stories which are more or less at the
same level all the time slightly more
difficult as you progress
the assimil material gets more difficult
pretty quickly so it starts very easy
very slow and gradually picks up speed
and increases in complexity one thing
that was interesting as i import these
lessons into link
you know the amount the number of new
words
doesn't necessarily you know get more
and more and more so you might have less
than 35 might be
40 new words and lesson 50 is 21 new
words so i'm able to go through
and pick 21 22 new words do those first
before i go to 40 new words which in the
assimil text might be earlier on because
again they have no idea
which words i know right so
but obviously it helps again it makes it
easier if you can have a gradual
progression and so
asimil fine
any of this kind of material is good
and it's fun to have something that i do
on
online and then i'm able to read it in a
book and you're kind of getting it in
both ways
but so the point is that language
learning for all of these reasons has
become easier and as we get going if
we're able to integrate some of this
learner material ollie richards
you know graded readers any other
material if we can integrate those
with link you know it's going to give us
a smoother progression
from say the mini stories through to you
know call it authentic content
i pointed out earlier that the netflix
movies are typically at a lower level of
unknown words
because the dialogue is kind of simpler
so these are all the things that we're
working on not only us other people it's
all going in the direction of making
language learning easier than ever
and i repeat if anybody is genuinely
willing to work with us in creating more
many stories point of view stories like
he did something then i did it and then
questions i mean you can see these at
length uh we are very interested because
i think that could help just another 50
60 stories takes us a little closer
another more opportunity to review the
same structures and the same tenses and
the same
preposition usage and so forth
before we launch into the authentic
material
and getting back to the cbc it's
astounding that they're going to spend
16 million dollars and doing something
that from a language learning
perspective essentially is already
available anyway thank you for listening
bye for now